so lizzo uh the singer lizzo up until a
few months ago was considered the
champion of positivity and optimism and
hope and love and rainbows and uh
recently her reputation has taken a
major hit with with various former
employees and backup dancers accusing
her of being abusive uh you know in
various different ways behind the scenes
and
um what we see is that once those
floodgates are open there's no stopping
it and then you know once we start
hearing that some famous person is there
oh they're actually a jerk behind the
scenes can you believe it never never
would have guessed as soon as that
happens then everyone who's worked with
that person is lining up and looking to
get their piece of the pie and say oh
you know I was victimized too
so this is the latest this is the latest
yet another lawsuit against lizzo
related to this
uh and here's the report on that from
NBC
pop star lizzo facing a brand new
lawsuit from one of her former workers
yeah that's right and new exclusive
reporting from NBC's Diana dasrath and
Tim stello a fashion designer claims her
team was mocked and bullied Backstage on
tour she goes on to allege that lizzo
allowed Behavior like harassment and
racial discrimination to happen NBC News
correspondent Stephen Romo joins us now
so Stephen can you walk us through some
of these new allegations and has there
been any response from lizzo or anyone
else named in the lawsuit well this
lawsuit does have some similarities to
the lawsuit filed by her former dancers
for Liza we told you about those last
month there are some differences here
though Asha Daniels a fashion designer
who says she toured with lizzo filed
that suit today she started working with
the pop star about a year ago she
designed clothes for her dancers well in
this lawsuit there are some troubling
allegations against lizzo but more
specifically against her wardrobe
manager Amanda namura Daniels alleges
nevira forced dancers to change out in
the open did stereotypical impressions
of black women called perform Homer's
dumb mocked their weight and the suit
even alleges namura used a slur and
threatened to kill anyone who put her
job at risk Daniels goes on to claim she
was forced to work seven days a week for
20 hours a day and was told to continue
working
on her ankle so that's the claim
maybe it'll surprise you maybe this
maybe my take on the surprise you
slightly I'm actually a defend lizzo a
little bit I mean I have no doubt that
she's a total fraud and a-hole and
everything she says about oh positivity
uh I have no doubt that all that is
nonsense
but this is this is what I'm saying it
you know when you first get the claims
from someone saying this person's
abusive behind the scenes it might be
true it might not be true
but then
you know the claims that come after the
people come out of the woodwork after
that
like almost always full of it this is
the same with me too the me too stuff
it's like you have the initial claims
might be true might not be true
uh
varying degrees of credibility with
those
it's always after that it's like a few
weeks after that when you get the really
wild stuff
because at that point people figure well
hey I might as well go for it you know
this person's reputation has already
been dragged in the mud might as well go
in and go for it and so now we're being
told this other person threatened to
kill them if they don't keep working and
I'll kill you all
you'll all die
come on that didn't happen you know if
you're like most Americans you're
struggling to make ends meet and by the
time you pay the bill uh fill up your
car and grocery shop there's almost
nothing left everything is more
expensive and most of you are paying
these bills with a credit card Consumer
Debt Rose over one trillion dollars in
the last year this is the biggest
increase in 20 years if you're a
homeowner there is a way out you need to
call my friends at American financing
they'll put together a plan to pay off
that high interest credit card debt and
create meaningful savings for you every
month they're saving people up to a
thousand dollars a month in closing in
as fast as 10 days don't wait get
yourself into a better position call
their salary based mortgage consultant
today and see how much you can save 25
years of experience and 7 000 glowing
Google reviews speak volumes about their
ability to save homeowners money it
costs nothing to get started and if you
start today you could delay two mortgage
payments giving you greater savings up
front call American financing today at
866-721-3300 that's 866-721 3300 or
visit americanfinancing.net that's
americanfinancing.net
and there's a white woman behind the
scenes of the concert using racial slurs
against the black dancers that didn't
happen either that didn't happen
threatening to kill them that didn't
happen
unless it was in an obviously like
sarcastic joking way
uh seven days a week for 20 hours a day
also didn't happen no way that happened
do I have any evidence that none of that
happened no I just know that it didn't
it's just it's just this is what you
gotta have the finely tuned BS detectors
and they can take you far in life and
you can just hear that and get that I
don't think that happened that probably
didn't happen
so
significant only because there's a one
or only time I will
sort of defend lizzo
even though I wasn't even heard I was
accused of it but still if you'd like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed